thank you so much for joining us at the
official launch of the national school
choice week special whistle stop tour
national school choice week begins today
and it runs until februari second and
our goal is very simple it's to shine
the brightest most positive spotlight on
the urgent need for effective
educational options for every child in
Los Angeles in California and across
this country this week is about the
future of American public education
today we stand in Los Angeles ready to
kick off a 3500 miles tour across the
nation carrying the simple belief and
proclamation that we appearance demand a
revolution in public education and our
voice is simply going to say give us the
right to choose the important thing
about choice is that I can decide the
kind of education as a parent
child deserves our system is failing
children all over the country because
it's not designed to succeed choices
choice today here in this room we have
Republican and Democratic speakers this
isn't about political posturing this is
about just a solid belief that with
great education we produce great minds
the only way we're going to change
things is to get powered the only people
who only care about kids
parents if i have money or if i don't
have money I still deserve a right to be
in power to make a difference in my
child's life we fight together we
celebrate together and most of all we
stand together for school choice we're
going to count down together and then
we're going to ring this Bell and kick
off this tour and this week three two
one
we've just boarded the national school
choice week special which is going to
make 14 stops across the country this is
an opportunity for families who really
want to change things in this country to
actually make a difference and they are
see you guys in the back to go
there thank you very much